يفديني بريجورجين مؤسس قوات فاجنر يقف
كقائدا عسكريا عند جبهه بخموت رجل الاعمال
الروسي لقب هذه المدينه العصيه على
مقاتليه بمفرمه اللحم في تعبير استعاره من
مهنته السابقه في مجال اداره المطاعم ومن
شراسه المعارك على الارض بعد جنود خطوط
المواجهه في فصل الشتاء احرز مؤخرا مرتزقه
فالينر تقدما ضمن محاولاتهم لتطويق
المدينه ويحرسون هنا على تسميه بخموت
باسمها السوفيتي السابق ارتيموسك مركز
بخموت قريب جدا اقصد كم تبعدون عن العدو
نحن نبعد 400 متر من العدو العدو هم
الجنود الاوكرانيون الذين يقاتلون في
الخنادق لحمايه مدينتهم وعلى الرغم من
تقليل المحللين العسكريين لاهميه هذه
المدينه من الناحيه الاستراتيجيه لكن
رمزيتها كبيره بالنسبه الى الاوكرانيين
هذه هديه الرؤوس اليوم هو يوم جيشهم
العدواني سارسلها
العزيمه الى جانب الدعم العسكري الغربي
عوامل تساعد الاوكرانيين على الصمود يقول
الجنود هنا ان القوات الروسيه بتقدمها
اصبحت اقرب لمرمى نيران المدفعيه
الاوكرانيه ومدينه مناجم الملح والجص التي
شهدت اطول معارك الحرب ما زالت تقاوم
الهجوم الروسي بعد ان تحولت الى مدينه
اشباح وبقيت جمله على الجدار المتداع تقول
ان بخمول تحب اوكرانيا